big wins and of course another win we'll
talk about is the game with richard
rapport who's been sitting here
patiently thank you very much timing is
what it is we simply had to cover that
richard today's game
what did you feel about it you did have
a difficult day yesterday actually
before i go to that i don't want to have
bad memories but yesterday you could
have easily liquidated the position and
made a draw what made you go for it
instead of doing that yeah yesterday was
a very um
well a very traumatic day for me you
know i haven't i think i haven't lost a
game before classical game uh before
this like for two years or maybe more
than two years something like 60 games
you know and then i have this position
um
basically where i think there are like
two results i mean i can force a draw
like pretty much anyhow i could um
i didn't have to allow him to take on f6
and enter that but i i chose to do that
for some strange reason and after that i
you know i could just trade queens in
time trouble on b3 for instance it would
be a draw i could take on g3 it would be
a draw like
i was looking for chances and you know
like uh that time was sticking i have
like 30 seconds to move and then you
know i wanted to go rg7 which is a good
move and then i look at the clock it
says like okay two something yeah and i
just uh forgot that i already had my
rook on g7 so i moved it one square
behind it's right gs i press the clock
in one second i'm like okay completely
in shock and then he goes f3 and i was
like i thought that rook c5 is very
unpleasant and he goes f3 and i did the
same thing twice i repeated the same
episode you know i wanted to take
after some okay some surprises and
everything rook takes h2 and king takes
h2 and then f6 and then i again do the
same like clock is ticking and i forgot
and i started with f6 and it's move 40
and i can just resign basically so i was
uh you know pretty upset about that
let's put it this way yeah i can imagine
you did bounce back today though coming
into this game frame of mind uh you got
a great position take us through some of
the moves uh yeah you know of course uh
yesterday's game play uh played an
effect on this game right because i was
thinking to play um
maybe more ambitious than i i would
normally have i don't know
so i played g3 first move which
you know has no i don't know special
intentions and he played this
97 line yeah i was expecting actually he
will go to six and try to get some
greenfield uh
i mean after knight f3 try to get some
greenfield kind of you know business on
hoping for me to play d4 and then he
will
transpose back to his usual um
yeah and then even 97 which was a bit of
a surprise and i
i didn't really check this line ever so
i just thought to play some uh
some moves i think there was some games
here but i might be wrong
so we
we have a uh fisher 960 a
fisher chestnut random chess tournament
coming up and we were thinking that you
were trying to get a
leg up on that event
it got a little bit confusing yeah yeah
exactly
uh
and then after bishop f5 yeah i think e6
and then i take i mean i took he took
and i think maybe like what would have
been possible also that i want to go for
bishop g5 right and i want to get this
position like bishop takes f6 he takes
back i don't know queen d3 and i want to
play
in the structure e3 b3 and c4 with
having uh
with not allowing him to trade the
knight for my bishop let's say uh
something like this
and you know knight moves i know to e2
or c4 and then i play c5 like this is my
plan basically yeah right and um yeah i
i'm not sure if i could have done this
bishop g5 immediately i figured i will
go queen d3 he will go g6 and then i
will go bishop g5 and then he went queen
d7 yeah and it's a little bit changed
things like after g6 bishop g5 will be
uh a better version because like bishop
b4 is queen e3 check so he has to go
like bishop e7 i mean
it's not a big deal but it's a nice
check to give you
and then he has to go to b7 and then i
can do this i mean if i wanted to like
take take and or castles something like
that
and you get everything that you want
which is e3 b3 knight e2
uh c4 and it's play on two yeah i feel
like this is kind of unpleasant for him
unless he went to queen d7 which is i
think uh you know like i don't know if
it works but it certainly um made an
effect on me
so i played castles he played bishop
before and i'm an nd one right and i was
thinking okay um
i wanted you to go for this 91 idea
actually after bishop before but i
wasn't sure like how to make it work so
i just did it immediately it might have
been you know not that precise i don't
know um
here i i was kind of banging the table
for bishop h3 a move
uh that
yeah actually i was considering stuff
like that but after g6 what's your idea
like i was thinking
uh just uh more or less uh the same as
in the game but
you're still aspiring for e4 but
maybe
the fact that you've provoked g6 though
yeah i wasn't sure because i freed his
queen and then he can unpin um as well i
was actually thinking i want to play
after g6 knight d3 and knight takes f5
premium right pretty much ah that would
be awesome yeah just positional
sacrifice and play for f34
uh i was thinking this could be
interesting actually the main reason i
didn't go for this because after knight
xf5 if he goes k8 i am still pinned and
i wasn't really sure how to unpin yeah
so i was like you know if
i can even uh you know he can even lose
the tempo okay it's kind of ridiculous
yeah so
that's pretty funny
nice
all right so
in the game you after knight d1 yes
shuffling in the background yeah 26
shoot g5 yeah and things get very
concrete right because we have this
argument that he wants to play you know
an se4 he wants to go on the e3 square
and i want to play e4 and we are both
you know it's very time-oriented mata
right yes so i have to go c3 i think
it's pretty forced here it reads i go
rookie one yeah and he took the pawn of
course it's normal quincy two back a4
and i think this is like where things
were critical i don't know
um maybe i was thinking um yeah he
played h6 yeah which is normal i think
also he could play other moves but h6 is
like i mean he could play g6 maybe as
well i don't know i was thinking it's
maybe not completely uh stupid to play
g6 and just to
get ready for you know i i think i
cannot take anything right now
the e1 yeah and prepare for e5 yeah and
okay here i could have retreat it's also
interesting but i've oops i've
absolutely i know my my yeah i uh
i hit the wrong uh key yeah this is
trickier
it is especially when you're up here
with this uh keyboard uh sorry uh so
after h6 yeah yeah yeah i felt like i
could also retreat but this was very
forcing i mean the take on f6 right
bishop c1 i don't know like i thought
yes he might have some ideas like i
couldn't calculate it so much like i saw
that fe fe for instance doesn't work for
him like fefe knight e4
uh knight e4 f5 doesn't work because of
knight f6 check
ah no no no take here f5 for black yeah
like something like this think he cannot
just go for
stuff like this but like i don't know
like i thought okay this was also very
much playable okay but it gave me two
yeah i took e5 f4 i think he played well
h5 i mean it's very forcing i have to do
something concrete g4 and okay yeah this
was mistake he also said after the game
i think he should just uh hold the
structure
uh somehow right i was planning to play
something like maybe knight h1 like next
but it's it would be really complex here
like i want to basically you know
provoke something like for instance c6 i
don't know knight h1n
and if h4 i have some queen f2 stuff
going i don't know and if he takes i
just play f5 so
like something like this was my plan but
of course i could easily lose here as
well so um it's not you know yeah after
this queen d1 i i thought okay i'm doing
you know reasonably well yeah and you
know i think the attack is just flowing
i mean i'm i don't know if i played it
you know really precisely or not but um
it's just i have so many attackers and
the phones in the center again doing a
really good job zone
visually it just looks yeah
there was just one moment uh right here
that
well unfortunately
the engine pointed out a really really
nice variation oh okay for sure i missed
something big
c3 takes d4 rather prosec but why didn't
you take the bishop what were you afraid
of
uh you're going to tell me someone
whatever knight takes and queen takes a6
there goes the house right queen takes
a6 yeah that's a real pity actually yeah
it's very pretty it had been really cute
to play yeah yeah that would have been
nice
um okay you didn't win the brilliancy
but it was a good game yeah very good
game uh richard how do you feel about
your tournament
uh
now
uh
you know okay 50 is good especially when
the
before the game is minus one so you know
yeah that is
certainly nice but uh yeah overall i'm i
i don't know i mean i'm still under some
kind of effect from uh
this unnecessary loss uh you know i i
can't really be happy about this win but
sure uh it's nice to win a classical
game against such a clever player i
think actually this was our like first
game ever against peter and okay i have
huge respect for him so
um yeah of course i feel you know much
better looking forward to the rest
thank you so much richard uh good luck
for the rest of the tournament uh
alejandro uh
maurice any questions for richard well
a question that you had earlier and it
seems that it's he's not fully over it
but richard we've been wondering how do
you recover from a loss and are able to
focus on the next game and in this one
it seems you haven't actually given up
on that loss that it still bothers you
what's uh your state of mind in this
kind of scenarios uh yeah you know i
think i'm going to carry that with me
for quite some time
especially because i don't know
i mean all the circumstances combined
but you know i'm i guess at the end of
the day it comes down to you know
enjoying playing chess him like i
thought okay i have a i have a wide game
uh okay i am playing a great opponent uh
let's uh you know try to give my best
and
maybe try to have some fun and of course
i missed queen takes a6 so i didn't have
as much fun as i could have but you know
it comes down to it i think well thank
you richard